well as you may have seen early voting
in nevada started on saturday and it's
already on track to be a big success
compared to 2016.
in clark county alone nearly 80 000
people have already voted
now that includes 29 500 just yesterday
some of the busiest sites are in the
centennial center in the northwest
downtown summerlin and the arroyo market
square
now when it comes to mail-in ballots
more than 105 thousand
have been sent in so far clark county
began
counting mailed-in ballots today so
here's how it works
after being verified election department
staff take the secured ballots out of
the vaults
and feed each ballot through the
tallying system to help the process go
smoothly
the election department reminds you to
sign the envelope so it can be processed
and counted eight news now is your local
election headquarters
you can find updates on the presidential
election on our website
eightnewsnow.com as well as everything
you need to know about voting
in this year's election